Come on, throw me one!
I'll hit your pathetic pitch with my bat
and score a home run!
Dammit!
This is so embarrassing, I'd rather die.
But I've got no choice.
As long as I'm the batter,
that Mask won't be able to hit me!
Don't tell me this is a dead ball!
An impressive strike.
My thoughts were right!
There's no reason to be afraid now!
-Okihara!
-Yes!
Honjo!
At your level, there's no chance.
What?
At your level, you won't be able to become
God of this realm.
Well done.
You utilized the pre-Mask nature
of this human.
"Realm"? "God"?
What the heck is he talking about?
But if you're already struggling with me,
you're far from being God.
Does he know
a crucial secret about this world?
I'm glad I got to play baseball
in the end.
Hey, Honjo.
Was I not supposed to shoot him?
No, don't worry.
You did great, Okihara.
At your level, you won't be able to
become God of this realm.
What does "become God" mean?
I assumed the goal of this world
was to get to the helicopter,
but is there a different objective?
Are you okay, Honjo?
Now's not the time to think.
Okihara, let's head back for now.
Yes.
The mention of "God" bothers me.
I better be more concerned about
the "realm" right now.